[Music]
i wanted to talk to you are you playing
any video games that is a prepared
question but it's genuine
[Laughter]
i want you to know it's on the card but
i jumped down to like five
this was free styling yeah off the dome
that's just natural rapport natural
rapport
just in case
[Laughter]
favor this is all it says favorite video
games
[Laughter]
right now i'm playing a lot of animal
crossing new leaf
what is that why did you laugh
is that a is that a it's a great game
it's a fun game where i'm the human
mayor of an animal town
[Applause]
everybody answers to me which i enjoy
and i go around trying to make fountains
and you know just get my get my bills
paid
it's like a fun video game it's a zoo
no it's a town
that i run you may come and visit if you
like
i'm the mayor
i wish you were the mayor of my heart
you get re-elected every year
see this is the weird i know isn't it
sweet he's just he's just sunshine your
sunshine uh i got the last question this
is new to me i'm used to just talking
and talking yeah but spencer gave me the
last oh he's now giving me the wrap one
so no
what happens when we die
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'm here with you i don't want to put
you dead over
lights out or something else
um i don't believe
now oh pete
we're going to start into a 20 minute
conversation that's okay we'll put it
online i believe energy never dies p and
we'll just transfer from one form to
another and things continue to go on and
that's i mean
that wraps it up if you ask me
yeah there you go
just maybe
your ego dies
but your energy keeps living and maybe
when you pass you wake up and you're the
mayor of an animal town
run functions everybody
my friends
thank you
[Music]